so i'm gonna start with congratulations
on your first feature um
uh i i am so curious though what did you
what did you learn making this that
perhaps like you weren't expecting going
in that you'll take with you to like
future projects
animation is long and tedious
i knew that going in by the way but i
think i've really experienced it like
full
fully on this one because it's the first
uh i think it's the first project that i
like start and wrap you know so you do
the whole thing and there's so much to
do um it sounds so obvious what i'm
saying but i think
until you've really experienced it even
though i've been in animation for so
long until you really experience it
every single little step that we have to
uh to go through to actually
be able to deliver the film
it's incredibly long it's incredibly
specific and and and and uh and and uh
tiring is not the world but like it it
feels like it's never ending
um so it's like prep yourself for a long
adventure long haul basically even
though you know
you kind of just look a little bit ahead
of you and not look at the mountain
that's coming in front you know
um but no frankly in terms of like
creative like uh uh you know stuff that
i'm gonna take with me it's like really
is a human adventure you know it's some
like the one thing that i
as a as a leader of a project the the
one thing that really stuck with me is
that you
have to be really listening to the crew
and the cast and be able just to connect
with them
um
at a very um uh
uh in a very respectful way and just
being able to just uh uh listen to your
to your to your people into your to your
talents and production teams just to be
able to to make it through together in a
in
a
um
in a in a good way you know what i mean
like so that you know people come out of
this feeling fulfilled having learned
something uh having being happy to have
worked on a project like that and just
wanting to do it again with you you know
and i think that's to me that's the most
important thing you know because you
create a community of people that you
really can trust and they will give you
a hundred percent of what they have you
know i've spoken to so many directors of
uh animation
and they all talk about how radically
things can change during the development
process over the years of making
something so for this project did you go
through any sort of radical changes
thing like was the film almost something
completely different
no not at all actually
uh it's interesting because i mean i
mean the very first draft of the script
is not what you see uh the final but
it's kind of like almost the case i
think you know because i arrived uh that
first rough was written and so i had
obviously my own thoughts and then also
brought that idea of just
of making it kind of a genre film like a
heist type of movie so that that forced
us to just adapt things just to fit into
the genre
but
in terms of the
in terms of the
the look in terms of the music in terms
of the character design the the the the
the cinematography and everything all of
that was very defined early on
and
everybody just stuck to that vision
and decided to go with it and
i remember very clearly because
very early on i just did a quick
storyboard trailer of that film
uh just to as a proof of concept you
know
if you look at that story about trailer
and you look at the movie now it's
basically it in a weird way you know and
so
i mean obviously there's no colors and
there's no it's it's it's storyboards
but you know i mean like there's the
tone is clearly what you see now
uh and and uh and i think so therefore
there was not there was not like any
curveball there was nothing that was
like strikingly uh
so maybe it's luck i don't know
but
i didn't experience that and i'm so glad
i didn't because it was a it was a
fantastic experience
i mean we we got our share of
um tough times we scoved obviously
but that's for everyone you know that's
not the that's not the traditional
problem that you face in animation for
sure uh what are you actually most
excited for like families and for
audiences to see in the film
i think it's just like being uh
for the for the for the families just
like like for the first time having the
kids kind of dive into that uh
uh
genre of heist movies and caper movies
that i think
you know when they are not very it's it
doesn't happen often in animation that
you have a whole movie that is kind of a
uh
a heist movie in a way
and uh have the the kids be exposed to
it because those are movies as us as
adults love so much and i think
i'm very proud of how we managed to make
it you know uh reachable or
understandable for children you know and
i think they're gonna have a blast just
following this gang of friends
uh going through that adventure and yet
um you know enjoying the the twist and
the and the and the cons and the and the
action scenes and the all the all the
bells and whistles that make that genre
just such a fun fun drawing to watch and
follow you know
yeah um i gotta rap i'm just gonna say
that i i think there's a lot of kids who
are gonna be like wait what as certain
things are happening
yeah it's gonna be great um let's go
congrats on the movie and i hope you get
to direct something again very soon
thank you so much so much